do
it let's
go ladies and
gentlemen welcome
back to your favorite
[Music]
podcast with
gin
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back
to Griffin with Griffin live from riffin
with Griffin Studios today a lot of
Internet nonsense you know what I want
to talk about this Jonathan major
situation if you even know who that is
get a little bit into the
NBA 90day the other way crazy show bunch
of crazy stories on the internet some
personal stuff from me but as usual here
we are and welcome back once
again to
[Music]
real what's up y'all welcome back to
riffin with Griffin uh it's riffin it's
ER Griffin here with you once again
every Wednesday I'm doing a little lak I
had some personal stuff going on today I
might get into it I always get into
stuff like that but as usual thanks for
watching so hit the Subscribe button so
you can get you can get the
notifications and you can find out when
I'm uploading videos stand up and
whatnot so do that twitch baby I'm on
Twitch every single day so check that
out most days so you could be a twitch
subscriber a um YouTube member or a
patreon
member either one of those works out
good uh to be a riffin with Griffin um
you know so
supporter appreciate all the support as
always guys love that and you know what
I also want to shout out uh support to
our big sponsor of the show door Dash
door Dash thank you for sponsoring the
show order now and enjoy holiday savings
with door Dash use code
rwg holiday to get 50% off up to $10
value when you spend 15 or more at a
convenience gross or select retail
stores at door Dash that's code rwg
holiday Griffin with Griffin rwg holiday
terms apply try it out you know what do
you got to lose um hey everybody welcome
back to riffin with Griffin um I got a
new computer set up so it's like all
right here we go yeah I got to go to
this to see what's going on uh hey you
guys thanks for being here once again um
what's going on this week um a lot of
stuff I guess right a lot of non sense
in the world so you know why not uh we
we we will get into
it let me just make sure I pull this up
90day 90day the other way I want to talk
about that today that just just these
people are because they hav the tellall
and I
absolutely love the talls I mean the
talls are my absolute favorite um yeah
so yeah perfect so I I'll have that
Gallery up so anyways welcome back guys
um thanks for being here like I say as
always I love your support I like when
people walk up to me and they're like
hey man listen to your podcast you know
so my little small But Mighty crew you
guys are here so you can check me out on
this I'm also on the golden hour with uh
brenen sha Chrystal Leia you know it is
what it is hate me like me you know it
is what it is you know we have fun it's
my buddies um so check that one out that
comes out there's a patreon and there's
a a um you know the free four free
episodes you know that you can see on
YouTube at the golden Hour podcast um
and uh let's see I am going to be at
cisa casino everybody so you might want
to come check me out over there too at
ca ca comedy Cantina it's at a casino in
New Mexico you know near Albuquerque so
that's like it's not a new year show but
it's the 29th and 30th four shows come
down to the casino look on my website I
got the link there if you're in the New
Mexico area if you know anybody in New
Mexico area please come check me out
that's going to be fun and first week in
January 5th through the 7th I'm back at
the La Hoya Comedy Store and those will
be my last shows for a while while I'm
trying to be a dad you know working that
out so that's uh exciting stuff going on
there exciting stuff going on there man
in the riffin with Griffin
Camp um so today I you know during the
podcast late today there's always
something going on but today was one of
those days so my stepfather bless his
heart he uh had to get a procedure done
today and then as you guys know if you
listen to the podcast my mom has
dementia so you know somebody got to
take care of her so I said you know I
would do he was like going to get
somebody you know he's going to hire a
service and I was like yo man I'll do it
what are you talking about but he knows
how busy I am sometimes and he's like
it's just you know that's what family
family sometimes what what's good about
family is not that they ask you to do
stuff that they don't ask you to do
stuff because they care about you that's
another form of people being good family
so that's what was happening in this
situation so um you know I said I would
do it so I go out there you know uh pick
them up you know then we drop him off we
didn't even drop him off we went inside
then it was going to take like an hour
and a half and so I'm just spending time
with my mom today it's like you know I
don't know I guess our dementia is just
progressing in a way that it does I mean
it's I guess it's different for
everybody that's dealing with it out
there my my heart goes out to you
because it is tough
but right now my mom she knows everyone
she thinks you know she's like waving at
everybody hi she's waving at people and
she just you know wants to talk to kids
she's having a little bit of trouble
walking now which is like it's hard to
see it's tough for me man I'm telling
you it's tough you anybody out there
that knows you know it's tough you
because you know this this person you
know a certain way your comfort and
they're just not the same person it can
be tough you know but you know it was
nice it was also nice spending a little
time with her cuz uh you know still
laugh a lot you know my mom and I like
in this little they live in this little
retirement place you know and um like
we're walking by the other apartments
you know and one of these apartments I
wish I would have taken a picture of it
because it was crazy but one of the
apartments they had like a bunch of like
sort of Christmas decorations and then
there was like a a light like a little
pug
dog but it looked like what what what is
that called when you like get the dog um
uh um I don't know what it's called man
like you get it stuffed what is what is
that called you know what I mean and I
could tell that this used to be a real
dog you know what I mean and it's just
the the person has the dog outside her
apartment door just sitting there this
this little weird
ass Taxidermy that's what it's called
Taxidermy so you know they got this
she got this little dog so my mom sees
it and she goes she don't remember
anything she's like I hate that little
dog and then we just like start laughing
and then we just you know had a little
moment but my mom's having trouble
walking right now too so like sometimes
we have to have like a um I had my
stepfather bought her a wheelchair so
like we did walk at first but then like
you know we were going to go pick him up
and then we walked down the hall to the
elevator and she needed to sit down then
I was like you want me to go get the
chair and then I could tell you know so
I just went and got her wheelchair you
know then we wheed her around you know
but she loves like seeing people like
it's just funny things what she's doing
now like she'll see like we're sitting
in this like you know waiting room now
you know she's looking out the window
anybody that passes by she's like oh I
know him oh I know her oh that's I know
that person you know and I'm at the
point now where you just go oh cool cool
you know what I mean I didn't want to be
like cuz at first I used to just argue
man I you know I don't I didn't know
about it I didn't know what you were
supposed to do or not do cuz in that
time before I would have been like you
don't know him who who that you know
that person who is it then who is it you
know I would have I'd have been a
monster like that but now I know you
just kind of you just kind of go with it
you know um so that was
cool uh with with that today you know is
what it is you know what I mean for you
people out there El what it
is so anyways let's get into some uh
comments before we go on to this week's
topics because I got a lot to get into
this week a lot of stuff to get into
this week so you know stay tuned let me
make sure my phone like wait let me
actually just get to this now make sure
my because my phone's connected I mean
it's it's weird when you when you a
oneman show I talk about this every I
talk about this almost every week where
it's like hey guys I'm a oneman show I
have to figure this out on my own and
sometimes in the middle of it I gotta be
like oops I got to go get this you know
what I mean so it just it works out like
that so all right I'll get one of
fishy's Beats ready and if you want to
send me a beat for the rap recap uh you
know it's just at ericeric griffin.com
um so where we at now let's just go to
comments we'll just go to a few comments
of the past few
weeks uh let's see yamunda Capa whatever
your stupid name is just two hearts
thank you I love those crazy Jim Heath
just Griff with an exclamation point
[Laughter]
okay let's
see uh let's see um what else we got
here somebody said Stephen Tyler PJs
Tony Phillips talking about the Paulie
Shore episode somebody said I love
another one love
paully let's see ma MAV Miller I'm 25
and live alone so it's probably much
easier for me than you but working out
in the evening like 7:00 p.m. is my
favorite a nice little night cap after
work and your responsibilities for the
day are finished up you know what uh
math Miller I actually 100% agree with
you um I actually when I finish this
podcast I got to go work out um oh man
what oh I didn't realize how late it was
wow this might end up being a short
episode or I'm going to have to drive to
my
workout I just realized how late it was
and when I have my uh my my my my
workout today I'm about to hit the guy
up during the podcast like I'm live
podcasting I got to hit on my trainer yo
man I'm going to be late just getting it
set up took way too long but anyways I
love working out at night um so yeah and
the workouts have been great and I do I
like that walking home in the evening
it's like cool out and I'm I'm I'm all
like walking with my chest up high
because I've been pumping all these
weights so it's uh it's actually pretty
good
so I do enjoy all that yeah man this I
as I'm looking at this now we definitely
uh
um see this is my trainer texting me
right now so this is like live doing
this right right now
um you know I'm G to tell him I get
there at
six
um
here but I want to do it I'm telling
them right now I said let's do I I'll
get there at 6 let's do a short one but
I want to do do it you know what I mean
so yeah so uh anyways anyways yeah I'm
trying you know it's like he doesn't
know I'm telling I gotta do a live
podcast and I gotta I do a live podcast
I gotta finish I'm literally live
now oh I should I should send him the
link huh you know what I mean I should
send him I should send him the link so
he could like cuz he'll be like what
what are you talking about yeah but I'm
going to do that right now I'm going
send him a live link but anyway working
out has been great guys I really enjoy I
I didn't even realize how
much um I didn't realize how much the
working
out like I I it's like you feel you feel
so much better your your whole just your
whole body everything about what's
happening you just feel so much better
so shout out to my uh trainer who's been
going so anyways that's going to be all
the comments for today cuz like I say we
got to really uh get to it you know what
I mean we got to get to it today cuz I
do have a lot to go into today there's
so many great stories on the internet
but let's let's first of all let me just
get into this I don't know if you guys
watched the show 90day fiance 90day the
other way man this show is has been
absolutely crazy man these
couples I mean these couples are
absolutely crazy so I don't even know
all their names I don't I don't know all
their names but let's go to this right
now dude this is just this is just crazy
so these like like like this that that's
a gay couple he's like 60 and this
dude's like 25 or 30 he's got a little
girl and they live now they live in
Mexico so he went the D the the the old
gay dude who has also has three
daughters he had triplets so he's been a
father he moved to Mexico to be do dads
with this dude and he's got a little
girl his family hates that he's gay and
they going to move to Mexico but now
they going to have another kid with a
surrogate he's 60 not hating cuz I'm old
my damn self and about to have a kid
this couple right here this guy claims
he slept with 20,000 women lives in like
Ukraine or not Ukraine but like he lived
far away you know so in in Eastern
European and this girl goes over there
and as soon as she gets there she's like
you got to change your bed you told me
you going to change the bed cuz you all
these women you've had on your bed and
she's sleeping on the couch but she
crazy he's controlling you know what I
mean you this couple
Filipino okay he moves to the
Philippines they live in this rural area
he all he do is play video games he gets
her pregnant now they having a wedding
and and then the wedding nothing but
like Locust it was like a b ibal a
Biblical attack of locust come for for
for this couple man but they're young
they're too young it's just like why why
would you move and my God I don't even
want to talk about it this crazy couple
she's controlling this dude's a cheater
she don't caught him cheating he's using
her for money so she moves to the
Dominican Republic right and he's like
was living with his mom and now he gonna
move in with her because she moved all
her stuff here and now he's like taking
money out of her bank account he's like
hey I thought we were married uh you
know she wants he wants her to buy him a
car and she acting but then the thing
too is she acting up too he's like well
let's go move to America and she's like
I don't want to move to America what are
you going to do in America it's like
they are the worst couple ever and look
at this dude he's this big musclebound
dude and she's this little roly poly
chick with with a mouth on her like
they're not a match so if obviously that
relationship didn't work out this crazy
couple this dude live in South Africa
okay I don't know if y'all know about
South Africa it's not safe you got to
have security he's not even that wealthy
she moves to South Africa right to get
they get married now she in the house
all day and stuff and she he comes home
and she's like I don't want to live here
anymore what he's like well we're
married she's like yeah I know and then
she leaves and then they and then so on
the tell all she been gone for 4 months
and she's like I don't even know what's
going on with our
relationship hey you know what's going
on with your relationship you left [__]
you you can't leave and think you still
married like crazy okay absolutely crazy
okay this is the I was telling you that
that's that couple that's the gay couple
Kenny and Armando oh this couple right
here I
if you are a spoiled entitled young
white woman why would you move to
India explain it explain it Lucy explain
it it makes no sense it's just the
family hates her she hates the family
she's yelling at him at the top of her
lungs they're always fighting it's like
what like first of all I don't
understand why you would go to a place
and not visit like if if if I was dating
somebody that was like foreign from
another country and I was thinking about
moving to be with that person trust me I
would go stay there for a month minimum
you go stay for a month just to be like
okay do I like this can I do the things
I want to do crazy so they having issues
and she's a monster oh this couple
whatever with this couple she's from the
Netherlands right and she got a best
friend that she's called she's NE nean
whatever you how you say people from the
Netherlands so she cheating on him he
cheating on her they broke up and that
to tell all you finding all this out but
another like couple that like that don't
know each other that well and they don't
make any sense why they together then I
told you about these two sarper and
shakina and he's like super controlling
and then she on the tell all she gonna
play of a voicemail of him telling her
he's all like babe don't e too many
carbs uh check the menu actually send me
a picture of the menu and I'll tell you
what you should eat cuz he's trying to
make sure she stays fit right but then
you hear that out of context and
everybody's like oh my God he's too
controlling how are you allowing this
and then she's like yeah but I like
being controlled you know it's like just
it's like other people's belief system
gets put on you know what I mean crazy
yeah so I will say check out 90day
fiance the show is the show's like so
bananas but like I love watching
it I just love watching it you
know let me get to the NBA real quick um
one thing okay so NBA um LeBron James
they won the n Season tournament I
thought the End season tournament was
great it it it brings attention to the
regular season and makes the regular
season more fun to watch gives it a
purpose you know all those dudes on the
bench who are only making like
$700,000 they they want an extra
$500,000 so they had incentive and you
know it it looked great LeBron James
gets another feather in his cap I just
don't know if he's going to last the
whole season like they they you know
they played hard now now what's gonna
happen who knows we'll see so I thought
the inseason tournament was a success
and then you know we'll see like there's
a lot of really great teams right now so
we got to let this this middle part of
the Season play out cuz then the the the
halves and Have Nots are going to just
really start showing themselves you know
they they really going to start showing
themselves but if I like I'm not a Laker
fan but I'm a LeBron James fan I would
really love to see LeBron James win
another M I would like him to see get
five get five and then go off into the
sunset or wait for your kid to come in
and play with your kid when you're 43 be
like Vince Carter like right now
LeBron's Elite but I can still see him
playing another five years just being
like a he's a bench guy he's coming off
the bench but if his ego can handle that
I just don't know if it can I mean I
think it gets to a point where like
you're so great for so long that you
just want to be great but father time
does catch up it does make you look and
then when you play that Elite for that
long and you're that age you do
definitely go from like oh man to like
godamn get that fool off this off the
screen you know
um yeah so we'll see and then a big
thing that happened right now is like I
think Draymond Green's out of control
man I think that he's like I don't know
if he has I don't know if he wants to
really play basketball anymore in a way
I don't know what he's doing he's
getting a lot of technicals the the
other night he was flaring around and he
punched a dude in the face he's probably
going to get suspended I didn't see
today but when you see the tape you just
go ah come on man that was
unnecessary like if it wasn't him if it
was someone else and they made that
movement I would still be like ah you
knew what she was doing it it just
didn't look like oh I tripped and then
my fist punched you you know what I mean
it just didn't and so with his track
record you immediately don't give him
the benefit of the doubt and this kind
of stuff keeps happening to him far too
long man so I just I don't know I don't
know I think that the Golden State
Warriors they got a they got a problem
you know they got old ass Chris Paul uh
who's going to get hurt so just wait for
it just just wait he'll get hurt then
they're going to be stuck Steph Curry is
still great Klay Thompson is done being
Elite it's it's over for him he's not
Elite anymore he's a great he's a good
player solid player but he ain't gonna
give you 50 and a half you know anymore
or something whatever the great things
he did in the pass it's just it's not
going to happen
so they got issues Golden State Warriors
Got trouble so we'll see what happens
there but this Draymond Green thing man
I think it's like somebody got to sit
him down and be like yo man you have you
have to be on your p's and q's your best
behavior because the eyes are on
you I just don't know it just it's not
it's not a good look it's not a good
look so I I didn't put this on the
schedule to talk about but man I don't
know how to the Dodgers are paying that
dude arguably the greatest baseball
player ever you understand that dude
Otani pitches and hits at the same Elite
level that has never been done in the
way that he's doing it the Dodgers gave
him $700
million I'm like damn where's the money
coming from I guess the Dodgers are one
of those big organizations that they
have that private Network that you can
watch the dod and they getting all that
money themselves and and the Stadium's
lot full because there's a lot of you
know people that love baseball but
overall he's going to be the richest
dude in the league because no one else
is gonna be making money I just I don't
know about baseball U we let you know
what we'll pick up on this next week
we'll talk more about baseball next week
but yeah man tough that's I I just
that's a lot of money lot of money and
my thing about baseball is the angels
have two probably top 20 baseball
players
ever you know what I mean they for sure
got that two great baseball players ever
right and
then no no one goes to the games like
the stands are empty and stuff like what
if you had LeBron and Kobe or or you
know two great players like that on the
same team great players of their
generation great players of all time and
no one's going to the game your sport
has a problem you know your sport has a
problem all right guys uh our sponsor of
the show door Dash I want to thank them
and happy holidays everybody uh I use
door Dash I think you should too um it's
great man you know you get all the
savings from December 1st to the 12th
celebrate the season of 12 days of deals
on door Dash so you got to get to these
deals now I think there's like the deal
the deals are continuing because I know
it's past that right now but check it
out guys you need a little help with the
holiday season let door Dash be your
destination for holiday deals special
offers and everyday Miracles deck your
doorsteps with savings on gifts
groceries meals and more your favorite
stores you know it's like everything you
know they got you get stuff from the
convenience store you get stuff from the
grocery store and you can get stuff from
your favorite restaurants from around
take advantage of this deal guys if
you've never used door Dash do me a
favor just use it right now then it lets
them know people listen to my podcast
and they use door Dash looking to save
even more you can also be a dash pass
member you can enjoy exclusive offers
and perks all season long you'll get
zero delivery fees and reduced service
fees on eligible orders too all right
come on guys order now and enjoy holiday
savings with door Dash use code rwg
holiday to get 50% off up to $10 value
when you spend $15 or more at
convenience groceries and select retail
stores on door Dash that's R WG holiday
terms
apply yeah
baby I do suggest you do it I'm not just
saying that you know what I mean oh am I
Frozen oh no I'm frozen guys oh that
sucks
oh no what a nightmare guys what a
nightmare okay I I I know what to do I
just got to change this down to this all
right am I back I should be back I
should be
back yeah man
uh yeah I I um the uh what do you call
it something's going on with the my HDMI
the capture card that I have my thing
hooked up to for some reason and it's
like it's detecting a lower frame rate
so when it does that the the the the the
thing freezes so I got to keep track of
that
so yeah let's see what it's saying oh
yeah I'm getting I'm only getting
46.9 for a frame rate so I have it set
for a frame rate that it can't handle so
like I have to like put the frame rate
down just to like so so that it won't
freeze I I'm not a tech person so I
don't know how that works but the people
listening it doesn't matter cuz you you
don't you don't you didn't see me freeze
so whatever we just go it all right so
anyways let's get to this right now
um so a lot of stuff going on do you
guys I don't know if you guys know about
this um this guy Jonathan Majors he's in
those he's in a bunch he was in the
Creed movie and he was in the
um what do you call it he was in the uh
he's in 's what's it lowkey show you
know what I mean I know if you guys know
about that but the guy's like he's was
arrested him and his ex-girlfriend she's
suing him and there's all kinds of
things going on but now the court has is
releasing the documents they're
releasing recordings they're releasing
video footage surveillance footage and I
got to tell you it looks crazy see first
I'm going to say this I ain't for him
and I'm not for her if you want to be
like oh you know this guy's an abusive
person and you you want to believe that
fine but in terms of like the court of
law nothing is being proved right now
it's really crazy and and and I've said
this before on my podcast and I'll say
again we should not be getting this
information this it shouldn't be like it
should not be public like this until
there's a court trial and then once the
verdict comes out then they go okay
here's all the things for you guys to
decide if we were right or wrong but
doing it like this because he nothing
has been proven and now it looked really
weird you know for her case like this
thing right here this surveillance video
shows a fight with a girlfriend a fight
quote unquote but she's chasing him the
video is crazy it's like why is she
chasing him and then apparently they
split up in the night and then she went
to party at a club and then that night
she ended up in his closet passed out he
calls the police there's there's there's
video U you know sound of that where
he's calling the police and like I think
she's trying to kill herself the police
come she's like in his closet and then
she has these injuries and we don't know
are the injuries from him did she
already get the injuries it's like it's
like the what they putting out the
public we're just like well I don't know
what's going on you know so then it's
like you know obviously you got the
social justice Warriors who like love
jumping on a bandwagon being like I'm a
good person so the man is wrong you have
that tangent and then and then you have
the other side where the guys are like
that [__] is lying she could you know
it's like I don't know where I am in
that because I'm more sensible than that
I but all I know is we don't know enough
here's what I know we don't know enough
for this dude's life to have been ruined
that's the first thing and putting this
information out the way they are if she
truly is a victim you not making her her
look good this is unfair to her too the
whole thing is ridiculous right but this
is just one of the stories man like so
you got to take a look at that video I'm
not going to play the video but it's
just like it's it's absolutely crazy
man
um okay so I'm not going to work out one
my guy
tonight uh anyways cuz he's like dud you
know he's got to do something am I
trainer anyways so anyway this so I got
let me just slow down then so this looks
crazy this is a crazy story you know
what I mean and now we got to listen to
this okay okay we got to listen to this
so now here's a recording okay so this
is a recording of the dude talking to
the girl okay and this is supposed to I
don't know what this is supposed to show
let me make sure my camera's not frozen
hold up guys let me go back to this real
quick okay let me go back to this let me
go to this make sure we still good yeah
we still good all right
um okay yeah we're still good all right
so we can go back here and let's go back
to this uh so I don't know what this is
supposed to prove but this is a crazy
video recording of This dude this crazy
let's listen period This is a period do
you understand that yeah do you really
know baby do you really yes then how
dare you come home drunk and disturb the
piece of our house when we have a
plan okay so first of all I don't know
what he said there it sounded like he
was saying how dare
you like drum up or come home drunk or
about about her disturbing the peace or
him disturbing the peace but I don't
know what this audio is supposed to show
about him because when you listen to it
it it it just sound like a first of all
why is she recording okay so that so
she's crying and
recording
so I don't know man like if you go like
if you if you're in a abusive
relationship okay and you know you're
trying to get out of this and you're
trying to prove something and you have
the ability to record at any time this
ain't the conversation that you go he's
abusive and then and then let me hear
this
this you know this isn't the one that's
going to make me be like well girl you
got to get away from this dude I mean it
is crazy what he's saying but it don't
sound abusive let's keep going I would
like to get I would like to get to the
point where your friends know what job
I'm on and go I think Grace is going to
be at a
commission you what I mean yeah I W like
no no do you understand that because
because that team that unit right Grace
has has to be in a certain mindset to
support K Scott King you know who that
is that's Mar King's wife Michelle Obama
Barack Obama's
wife I know I'm not I I I shouldn't have
gone out I'm sorry let me just lay it
out for you
right if I am I'm just going to say this
my temper my [__] my trouble blah all
that all that said right and I'm not
saying I a great man a great
man I am doing great things not just for
me but for my for my culture and for the
world that is actually the position I'm
in that's real I'm not being a dick
about it I didn't ask for it I've worked
and that's the
situation
so
like I don't know what we're
supposed to take from that see my my
camera froze
again
um oh no it's not it's okay like I don't
know like what are we supposed
to I don't even know what to say I'm
speechless because so
apparently he's saying like they having
a disagreement about cuz she went out
and then she got like disturbing the
piece or she and you know it's like he's
this dude who's doing these Marvel
movies and and he's like yo what you
doing I don't know how this helps
her I don't know how it helps her at all
guys I don't know how it helps her
Jonathan major he's the black dude he
was in Creed he was like the villain in
Creed the new Creed Creed 3 he was in
Loki he was the black guy that was the
in Loki he was like the you know the one
that was uh you know he was the inventor
he made he was the person that made the
time stuff right uh and he's like you
know he was supposed to be the big
villain in the Marvel movies and stuff
whatever was supposed to happen then
this thing came out he was a you know we
we knew no information we just it just
was a headline he was arrested for
domestic violence or whatever with his
girl and now it's all coming out and I'm
saying if this is the information that
came out about that and he lost his
career because of this that's Terri
terrible it's terrible like I would hope
that more information comes out you know
like I I just think it's terrible I
think that we need more for him and for
her cuz right now this don't help her
case like it's it's freaking crazy you
know so I don't know I you you know what
I mean I just I just don't
know
um what to even make of this
right yeah this is just an absolute
crazy story man
um and I'm trying to find the other one
there was like an yeah that was the two
things like you got to find this video
of like her like it it looks crazy like
and even when you read the story about
like so they're having an argument
around the car right whatever's
happening at the car we don't know we
can't see anything and then he just
takes off and then she takes off after
him and then apparently she like like
saw a group of people and they were like
hey girl you okay or whatever's going on
cuz she's like acting hysterical or
whatever's going on right and then he
like mosy meanders past them and then he
goes home and she goes to a club and
parties that's what happened how does
that show abuse I
just to me this is like this is none of
our business how about
that you know I mean
you know if you are you're in a toxic
relationship with someone you know and
you're you're mad you're vindictive
you're mad cuz he's treating you a
certain way or cheating or or maybe he
just is like you know doesn't want you
to drink a lot or whatever the thing is
in their relationship if it's toxic and
then she decides oh you know what I'm
going to ruin your career I mean if they
have a toxic back and forth which they
viously do like why are we involved in
that but we are we got
involved worst case what's the worst
case scenario it's all bad that's my
point here on one hand he is abusive he
beat her or whatever and now she's
trying to like put him away okay let's
hope he gets thrown away let's hope the
evidence comes out and it's you know and
then get him out right the other side of
it is she's just lying because
she mad at him and they have a toxic
back and forth and then we got involved
we meaning the public got involved and
we're out here tweeting and saying dumb
[__] and then stupid ass Disney Marvel
who's like I don't know what they're on
they they on they on one and they decide
you know what fire him look what we did
guys we got rid of him is everyone happy
like who it's like no we're not happy
cuz how's that the Justice you know I
just I don't get it
man I don't get it it's really it's it's
really
crazy all right anyways let's go to some
more these crazy posts now this one
really bugs me and it touches it touches
what I do okay so apparently guys twitch
has decided to
allow in quotes artistic nudity in
response to widespread trend of topless
content game aing
popularity first of all I have so many
things wrong with this sentence okay
this
sentence so much wrong with it first of
all what the hell is Artistic nudity
like let's talk about that somebody
define artistic nudity for me please
artistic nudity so the titties are out
okay so okay that's the artistic part
like what are we talking about if we're
saying half nudity up to that means like
that's it for me like why would you
watch my gaming channel now when you can
go watch some titties some artistic
titties okay so I don't get that and
then this is the other part of the
sentence that I don't understand the WID
spread trend of topless
content what
okay the widespread Trend bro Google
topless content this [__] it ain't
widespread it's been here this ain't new
these these twitch is acting like
oh apparently nudity is a thing in the
past six months are they living under a
rock that's why it's nerd anytime some
anytime there's Tech
[__] anytime there's Tech [__]
there's nerds who have never the last
time they saw a vagina they were being
pulled out of
it and they're running things like this
big huge tech companies they obviously
and then they think that nudity is new
they're like oh topless
content did you guys know about this did
you know that uh people like looking at
titties they probably had a board
meeting um
apparently topless content is uh pretty
hot on the internet
really
so absolutely just shameful and
ridiculous right so I don't know I had
to go back and check and see if my [__]
is still on yeah it
is it's just it's just how dumb how dumb
are people dude you know how dumb are
people all right let's get to this one
now next one up on zillis
baby so they had this um director's
thing they had like the directors on
this website and they said you know they
had like a so apparently Christopher
Nolan won so they had these directors as
the top directors of all time Quinton
Tarantino Stanley kubri Christopher
Nolan Francis for Copa Steven spilberg
James camon Martin sces and Ridley Scott
so those are like the who's who of
greatest directors of all time um pretty
hot list you know I would I would have
liked to have seen Spike Lee in that
list I think Spike Lee has been a pretty
good director too but whatever you know
what I mean um and then Christopher
Nolan won I don't agree over Spielberg
over like I don't know if I look at
Quinn Tarantino I think a combination of
writer director is there anyone better
than Tarantino I just I don't know like
that opening of in glorious bastards the
dialogue between what's his face you
know the the the you know being the Nazi
talking to the people that are hiding
the Jews Like That dialogue and the
tension built in that dialogue and even
and in some of his other movies man Pulp
Fiction like I don't know I I think I
would take Tarantino should have beat
Nolan hands down I don't understand that
okay all right but it is what it is it's
like a modern thing I guess then you got
Spielberg and Scorsese that's like oh
man that's like Lakers vers Celtics you
know what I mean the old school and you
know you can't go wrong but I would take
Spielberg overcore Cy for sure um and
then and then I and then James Cameron
had no B like James Cameron versus
Spielberg yeah I'll take you know
spilberg even though James Cameron you
know this just I don't the the spectacle
movies I don't know if that has anything
to do with necessarily the directing you
know then Ridley Scott he he only has a
few movies that you could even name if I
asked you to name me five Ridley Scott
movies probably couldn't you probably
don't even know you probably like a
movie and didn't even know Ridley Scott
was the director so Ridley Scott Mar
Scorsese James Cameron Steven Spielberg
Francis Ford Copa but that just goes
back to like Godfather people and he
hasn't done much since he that guy has
iconic movies but they're all 40 years
old so that's tough Christopher Nolan
you know all I know him for is Batman
and a few other movies Stanley Kubrick
this that's a he's a weirdo on the list
yeah he he that anyways and then quit
again Quint and Tarantino so for my
money of all the people on this list I
would take Tarantino as the greatest
director of all time uh because he has
got a great combination of directing and
writing so there was that great story
from my one of my favorite websites um
where is it dude I'm sorry I keep
pressing the wrong button here here we
go oh it's this one here let's keep
going okay so now I want to show you
guys this video there's a trend of like
what dudes are supposed to do on the
first date I don't know if this video is
real or if these two fake this but this
is a prevalent feeling that I think
people have so this is this girl talking
about this date she went on I'mma play
the
audio no no I I can't believe this y'all
look at this so he told me we're going
out for drinks right why we pull up out
of
Starbucks what's wrong with Starbucks
I got dressed like this to go to
Starbucks okay first of all let's stop
there the chick acting like she in an
evening gown she acting like she dressed
up to go someplace fancy she got on a
tank top what I dressed up like this who
you talking about I put a comment up on
this video she acting like she's
Cinderella and it's 11 like she's
talking like Cinderella and it's like 12
and like she don't even know that the
magic went away and the Gown is gone
that the Fairy Godmother gave her and
now she dressed in her in her like uh
she dressed in her uh her maid clothing
her regular ass poror clothing and she's
going like this like Cinderella be like
yo I dress like this and people like uh
you better take another look you don't
have a gown on anymore that's what this
chick sounds like man this is bananas to
me yeah I told you it was going to be a
casual date Birch date should be casual
this is a PSA to all you ladies uh get
to know somebody before you go on a date
because this is first of all she says
PSA to all the ladies get to know
someone before you go on a date hey
[__] that's what this is that's why you
only going to Starbucks like good for
you dude pull up to Starbucks and see
how she acts you know what I mean maybe
that was just like yo let's get a
Starbucks of coffee cuz we about to take
an hour drive to such a such I don't
know where they are but let's say they
in La I'll be like yeah we just going to
get a quick coffee cuz I'm about to we
about to drive to Santa Barbara and it's
an hour and a half away and I got us
reservations at the night maybe she
don't know she don't know but this is
what getting to know is that's what's
crazy about it it's not a date don't do
that this is a cheap date you're
supposed to whine and dine me you're
supposed to be a man it's your excuse
here and you're supposed to be cooking
for me you're supposed to be a woman I
don't even
know right we're doing gender roles
right
yeah you know what when I see these
things and I hear someone talk and I get
all worked up like I do sometimes I have
to stop myself and just go
oh you're
stupid and then I could just let it
go like what's she talking
about he's she's like you supposed to be
a man she's like oh we're doing gender
roles okay then you're supposed to cook
for me you supposed to be a woman she's
like I ain't cooking for you I don't
even know you he's like exactly that's
why I'm only taking your ass to
Starbucks
[__] crazy absolutely absolutely crazy
all right let's keep going I just I'm
done with this story because this is
like this is a thing now this is like a
big thing like all these women like this
I saw another one the girl was like you
supposed to cut my steak for me
like
it's like so let me so so I'm taking you
out to a
restaurant and I I'm paying for it all
it's a fancy place CU you you acting
fancy so okay I'm about being fancy I
take you and you want me to pay for the
steak I'mma drop $250 $300 that's the
kind of steak house I would go to you
know and I got a oh let me let me cut
your steak for you and then you acting
all like this what's attractive about
that that's the thing too like like this
chick right here she might be pretty
maybe the guy was like oh she
fine all of the finest went away with
this video when her mouth
opened
crazy absolutely
crazy all right I gotta go over here so
I can check make sure we still good yeah
we still
good unbelievable you know what I mean
guys
all right so let's uh here's some other
crazy stories and then we'll get off oh
man this is going long I don't even
realize I ended up going long so
Oklahoma cop arrested for assaulting a
sex shop clerk who defended the cop's
wife in an argument about the size of
her sex
toys that's a lot to unpack in this
story
[Laughter]
right I
mean we'll be talking about out so the
cop got arrested Oklahoma cop arrested
because because he
assaulted the sex shot
worker because the cop's wife was in
there arguing about the size of her sex
toys so like did the cop come in cuz he
found some sex toys and it was a
probably like a huge black
dildo and the guy was
like what the hell is this and the sex
the sex shop guy was like what you
talking about that's a yeah that's
regular size sorry that you don't you
know she needs this because you ain't I
don't know what happened right but it's
like
how when you read a headline like that
this tells you everything you need to
know about the craziness of this
relationship this person you know what I
mean I don't even want to go into it
it's just as I look at it now I'm just
like this is what the world is now
people doing dumb [__] and they're being
put on the
internet all right oh my phone is acting
up
um all right here's another one okay now
this one was this is a doozy of a story
right here guys this is a doozy of a
story so this man insists his
12-year-old secret son
move in tells distraught wife and
daughter they can leave if they don't
like
it you see what I'm saying like that
headline right there tells you like so
much about this Rel so so the guy
cheated on his wife had a
kid now if it's a secret son that means
he knew about the kid has he been
sending money to the other woman has he
been in the son's life or like you know
like what is you know what is the full
story well they have the you know what
actually they have a full St I I
remember I did go see the full story but
I'm rushing through it right now because
we're almost we're coming up on the end
here so it seems as if you know he
cheats on his wife he's got the son and
now maybe the other woman's like yo I I
can't do this you I need help and now
he's got to be like all right I got to
come clean
so whose side you take in this but like
this is crazy right you got you got this
boy who he's just a little boy he's 12
he probably loves his dad probably it's
probably been a weird life for him he's
like well how come I can't spend more
time with you he don't even know he got
a sister you know what I'm saying and
he's 12 imagine all that lost time just
cu the guy was hiding this secret and
then you got you know now you got you're
This Woman This mom here's your daughter
and your husband comes to you like yo
guess what um so the spare bedroom where
you have all your crochet stuff yeah my
son is going to move in there and if you
don't like it you could leave and you
can take my daughter with you
what I mean this is the modern life
right now right this is the This Is The
Life of modern people uh the the
craziness of you know of everything that
goes on in the world
everything about this is terrible
everything about this is terrible Right
the dude is completely like he's wrong
and he's right he's wrong for keeping
all this a secret and and and just like
messing up a relationship between his
kids that they probably needed and could
have used Ander you know and he's wrong
and then he's right for finally being
like all right I got to step up sorry
but like and then wrong again you don't
go to your wife tell her yeah my my my
kid got to move in I'm so sorry I
cheated on you and I have a 12-year-old
son can we please work this out but he's
got to move in you know and then the
Ultima being like cuz you know she mad
imagine your your your spouse comes to
you like with a secret kid T and you're
like uh-uh that kid can't stay here and
he's like yo I pay all the bills so
guess what this my house so you can
leave or you can put up with my kid W
the resentment and I mean the therapy
that those children are going to need
the therapy that the adults are going to
need in this situation G what a it
sounds like a crazy sitcom you know
crazy that it's that's crazy this whole
story is crazy y'all it's absolutely
crazy and the last one is uh study says
eating pasta does not lead to weight
gain I knew
it let me say it again study says eating
pasta does not lead to weight
gain thank
you all
right that's
just that's just the fat guy moment of
the week you know what I'm
saying oh man X5 podcast dude why y'all
sending me that much money you guys are
okay I see why now I got to talk about
guys there's a great pock
the X5 podcast I was on it bunch of
great guys this dude owns this great
podcast studio and he's he's got all
these great fancy cars and I was on it
with David Murphy you guys should check
that out great dudes you know what's
funny man I was wearing the X5 hoodie
today but thank you for the Super Chat
Gary thank you um K he says Kyle nun is
the best direct director you got to
agree I don't know he makes the top
thousand I think you know what I'm
saying how about this best d one of the
best directors I've ever worked with
okay is that fair that's fair because
I've never worked with any of those
other
[Laughter]
directors uh thanks for all the super
chats Gary X5 podcast you guys are great
you know but anyways yeah man that's
that last story is just freaking bananas
man that's a banana story so I hope that
you know that family gets the help they
need because that's gonna be a struggle
man look guys we got to wrap this up
today I appreciate you guys watching
riffin with Griffin being a part of it
you know make sure you
subscribe hit that subscribe y'all
twitch I'm I'm since I'm I'm didn't get
to go work with my trainer I'm gonna get
on Twitch so make sure you guys check me
out on there uh and then you know
patreon you know and I'm I'm I'm really
let me tell you guys my idea what I'm
thinking about doing I think I'm gonna
go to a
like strictly I think I'mma do movies
reviews and show talk as my main thing
on Wednesdays and then I will do a
supplemental which will be like for
patreon twitch and YouTube
members and then Snippets of that I'll
I'll put out and it'll be when I go over
these like crazy stories and have my
crazy thoughts and I can just like go no
holes barred on that I think I'm going
to start doing it like that I'm trying
to come up with some stuff stuff cuz you
know I'm going to be home a lot you know
coming up you know I'm having this baby
and you know I'm looking forward to that
and life's about to change y'all but
anyways you know what time it is y'all
so you know what time it
is it's that rap
recap thanks for coming
back you know this be
slap and that's a fact
Eric G is
back k
k woo you got you your secret
son you bring him
home your main wife took a
run
NBA what more can I
say
uh woo J and majes that boy in trouble
unlike Bonnie
Rubble on the
Del his information shouldn't be
out [__] looking for
clout shouted
out H now thank you for watching riing
with
Griffin and
[Music]
listening
RI with
Griffin you know it's the
best tell your
friends better than
rest woo say it with your
CH uh uh all right
y'all worst rapper ever but I love doing
it cuz it's fun and I can to get my dad
[__] together thanks for watching riffin
with Griffin and once again I
will see
you next
[Music]
week